und sie persönlich base minister würde
sie reizen erfahrung einzubringen ein
ziemlich gereizt ich habe immer
abgelehnt wenn es da zu werden habe das
ist ja dankenswerterweise durchhalten
können aber auch diese frage sollte man
sinnvollerweise erst wenn man weiß wie
die wahlergebnisse aussehen obwohl da
müssen sie noch den grund sagen warum
wollten sie nie minister werden ja weil
das meine persönliche freiheit extrem
eingeschränkt hätte ich habe keine lust
dass ich mir zu hause vier
sicherheitskräfte vor der tür stehen ich
habe keine lust wenn ich eine kneipe
gehen will dass vorher anzumelden ich
habe muss man sich aber sofort mein lied
magische gründe liegen die haben mein
leben ist anders organisiert und es gibt
genug leute die in diese ämter drängen
meine persönliche freiheit würde zu viel
zu sehr eingeschränkt werden außerdem
bin ich langsam auf dem weg in die aus
der politik sozusagen raus zum ehrlich
gesagt das kann ich ihnen einfach nicht
abnehmen sie haben so ein spaß an der
politik sie haben auch so an ehrgeiz ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass sie sagen
nachweise was ich lese lieber im garten
zu hause aber ich habe schon dreimal
minister werden können und wollte es
tatsächlich nicht also das muss man ja
auch glauben
ich glaube ihnen dann ist wenn es also
auch da muss man sagen sag niemals nie
das würde ich auch sony an habe ja noch
einmal aber das müsst ihr müssen schon
dramatischen umstände eintreten nach
außen hat wäre das ein dramatischer
umstände es wird ein neuer
aussenminister möglicherweise gesucht
wir würden ja also wird definitiv 9
außenminister geben denn der jetzige ist
eine katastrophe für unser land aber
unabhängig davon schauen wir mal noch
einmal es macht den anhänger eines alten
indianischen strich worten ich machte
erst gedanken darüber was da auf der
anderen seite ist was machst du wenn du
weißt wenn du weißt wie du wolf
überfluss kommen ja wir wollen mal
reinhören was markus söder gesagt hat so
fdp
war der zweitstimme vielleicht
vielleicht können wir ja mal fdp oder
oder oder freie wähler wählen da eine
idee denn die fdp das kann ich sagen die
fdp ist eine zentralistische partei die
denkt an berlin big und wissing ist eine
stimme für die fdp möglicherweise eine
verschenkte stimme und besser aufgehoben
bei der csu liebe freunde das kann man
glaube ich sagen
also zweitstimmen kampagne ist es nicht
gerade für die fdp wir wollen auch von
henssler keine zwei schwimm kampagne
soll sich um seine eigene bewegende
bilder kümmern wir machen unsere sachen
und wir machen momentan besser als die
csu die freien demokraten sind
deutschland bei doppelt so stark wie die
csu also wenn die so weitermachen
erreichen sie ich rechne nicht mal fünf
prozent später partei aber wohl der
ärgert sie dieses negative campaigning
als wenn ich mir das anschaue denke ich
okay warum rede die csu nicht lieber
über inhalte anstatt jetzt auf
stimmenfang in dieser art und weise zu
gehen das ärgert mich überhaupt nicht
weil ich dokumentiert dass markus söder
keine ahnung hat der negative
campaigning wirkt nicht gegenüber
denjenigen die man negativ belegt
abschrecken sondern über diejenigen die
negativkampagne
betreiben amerikanische strategien sagen
immer wieder nicht ich kenne den killing
und ansonsten kümmert sich um die selbst
und nicht um die anderen
also markus söder hat keine ahnung so
generell oder in diesem konkreten fall
war der sind bayernkönig in berlin ein
zwerg was muss ich mich mit markus söder
beschäftigen die daniel günther main
wenn es aber zu recht gesagt nicht wenn
der söder so gute zahlen wie ein
schleswig-holstein da könnte er sich
melden aber wir brauchen keine
ratschläge von menschen die schlechtere
zahlen damals hier
[Musik]